update now here at noon witness
testimony has resumed and now day three
of the derrick chauvin trial
the fired minneapolis police officer is
charged with murder and manslaughter in
the death of george floyd
here's michael george with the latest
the teenage cashier who took a
counterfeit 20-dollar bill from george
floyd shortly before he was killed last
may
testified in the derrick chauvin trial
christopher martin says he
thought floyd appeared to be under the
influence and possibly unaware the 20
was fake
so martin offered to pay out of his own
paycheck instead the manager called
police
and martin watched the deadly arrest i
disbelieve
thank god why guilt
if i would have just not taken the bill
this could have been avoided tuesday's
witnesses included another teenager
darnella frazier who recorded the widely
seen video of floyd's death
it's been nights i stayed up
apologizing in
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting
and not saving his life
the jury has been listening closely to
all the emotional testimony
when frazier was on the stand one juror
who is a grandmother and child
psychologist
was taking notes derrick chauvin's
defense has tried to prove that the
on-scene witnesses were a potential
threat to officers
and might have distracted them from
arresting floyd you called him a bum
at least 13 times that's what you
counted in the video
that's what i counted yeah she got 13.
witnesses testified no bystander
interfered with police
the defenses also argued that chauvin
did as he was trained
and that floyd's death was caused by a
combination of illegal drug use and
heart disease
michael george cbs news minneapolis